Short and sweet review number five. We discussed a situation where a person accidentally did the terrible sin of washing a dirty milk utensil in a fleshig meat sink with dirty meat utensils. Terrible, terrible situation.
Well, we said even though it's so terrible, all the utensils can still be considered permitted for numerous reasons.
First of all, we know that the water coming out of the sink possibly was not a yad soledes bo.
Maybe it was below Yat Salat Yisbo, temperature, in which case it would not make any effect on the kelim, on the utensils.
Also, we mentioned there were shitas who hold, the opinions that hold that maybe a faucet has a status of iri klisheni,
which for sure does not transfer any flavor, even if it has iri klisheni on there,
Rama holds that that cannot forbid dishes as well.
We mentioned that most people use soap. Soap works as a po-game.
It ruins the flavor of the meat or dairy residue and stops any issues from taking place.
And we have the groundbreaking chiddish of Rav Moshe Feinstein that held that if as long as there was a little bit of cold water on,
Shulchan Aruch
POSKIM
and Dairy, for sure not using them together, but even if you would use the same dishwasher for meat
and then dairy dishes one after the next, it's still not something that the Ashkenazi Kiposkin
were okay with. First of all, they said that even though soap is used in a dishwasher, it's only
added later in the cycle, and first there is a non-soap cycle, which does give flavor. Second of
all, there are many times food particles, if they're stuck in the filter or in crevices, and those food
particles can make problems in contact, if they're in contact with the wrong type of utensil. And
And third of all, since the heating element is inside of the dishwasher, it might actually make the water mamisha klirishon,
which would, and you would not get the same allowances of a sink, of maybe being a klisheni.
However, the Sephardic posts were more lenient, and they allowed using the dishwashers for meat and then dairy,
Rav Ovadya even allowed using them together, again, assuming that the initial rinse cycle is cold.
There are many factors why the Sephardim are more make-all and more lenient.
First of all, they said even if the dishwasher is a klirishon, it's only iri klirishon,
They also are a fan of the soap being po-game.
And also, third of all, they say it's very unlikely that particles will become in contact with the dishes in a way that will be posing a problem.
In summary, though, there are many differences between how dishwashers work.
You have to know how your dishwasher works.
You have to then ask a Rav for guidance.
And then before a person uses the same dishwasher for both meat and dairy dishes.